Welcome to English in a Minute, where we teach you about idioms in American English.
Our language is full of fun expressions.
And here at the Voice of America, we offer you high-quality English lessons twenty-four seven.
But what does this mean?
I'm learning English at the university.
Where are you learning English?
I'm learning English with Voice of America.
Their Learning English website is available twenty-four seven.
Twenty-four seven? Wow!
Maybe I should learn English at VOA, too.
There are 24 hours in a day, and seven days in a week.
When you say twenty-four seven in a conversation, it refers to 24 hours a day, 7 days a week.
It is another way of saying all day and all night, every day of the week.
And that's English in a Minute.